so I'm here today to talk to you about
strategies towards improving utility of
your big data and if you don't already
have big data you might have it soon or
you may be consumers of it and may not
really understand how it works or how
you might be able to better advantage I
some of you may have multiple sets of
big data and you may not have originated
it what you need to use it so so where I
work is part of a US National Library of
Medicine part of the National students
to health and it really is a broad
mandate for providing information for
you all everything from consumer health
type information all the way to aspect i
work on which is a research-based
chemical information chemical biology
type data so i work at the US National
Center for Biotechnology information
ncbi which houses things like pubmed
which has like about one and a half to
two million users a day these are
terabytes of data they have genes DNA
sequences proteins but they also have a
resource that I work at called popcap so
whenever their genomes and whatnot
published they go in to ncbi and we
annotate and cause I on TV I'm not
really going to talk to you about
pubchem but just to let you know this is
our website if you're interested to
learn more about the project based on
some of the things that you learned
about today but I will mention that what
we're trying to do is to bring together
big data that I care about which is
things on the chemical information acai
and so that we know what chemical
substances are and what their biological
health effects are and these aren't just
drugs these are things like diesel fuel
or you know the bug spray that you put
on yourself you know the chemicals
inside what do they do and how are they
important to you and just give you some
idea of what our big data looks like I'm
and I don't really expect you to look at
all these different graphs but just give
you some idea of some of the basic data
that we have how is it grown over the
course of 10 years so in terms of
people who give us an information so
pubchem is an archived and so we depend
completely on people to push data into
this archive but as a part of that we
have very large number of chemical
substances that are being stored in
there we have on the order about 125
million chemical substance descriptions
of those about 50 million of them you
might consider to be chemicals chemicals
that you would think of as being things
like aspirin or or other things like
vinegar acetic acid and so on but it's
really grown as a function of time as
we've been around for ten years and
people caught wind of this and start
adding data in we sort of created our
own big data problem and we had to solve
a lot of really basic problems about how
to deal with this information one of the
first things we learned is that well you
notice that all data has errors and well
I would tell you that big data has big
errors and just to give you some ideas
what we're talking about here is you
know imagine that you have an error rate
of one in a million which is to say that
you have 99.999% data accuracy and
that's really a very good data accuracy
if you were to have this if you have a
trillion facts you have a million errors
you can you deal with a magnitude of a
million errors inside your data I will
tell you that as an archive and for
various reasons which I won't get into
we probably only have one or two 9s in
our information it's not that the
information is just completely erroneous
it's that you can get inconsistencies
when you start to combine large data
together based on what people think
about their information and what they
provided to you is to different degrees
of granularity it gives you different
aspects of the information that may or
may not be relevant to you and your use
case so what do you do to sort of help
stamp down and make the get as many
nines of data accuracy that you can
and you can try manual curation and
people talk a lot about curation but
their limits about what you have and in
fact many of the resources that are put
inside our archive is curated they've
already done curation but what you find
is that you know it has its limits we're
human we make mistakes and you may have
a record that record may have tens or
hundreds of facts inside that record
some percentage of them are going to be
wrong because somebody forgot the dot
and I are cross a tea somewhere or they
capitalize something they shouldn't have
and suddenly become something else so
what do you do so what does it go
through is a series of strategies to try
and improve to sort of demonstrate ways
that you can prove your your error or
eliminate the error or somehow clamp
down on it but also ways that you can
structure the information that you have
left and I'll just go through these
really quickly and then I'll give you
examples of each one thing you need to
do is you need to understand your
information that you have make sure you
understand the the scope of what you you
have you need to do some type of data
normalization to your data if you just
take it as is you may be very unhappy
for it you need to trust your data but
you better to cross check it to make
sure that it's what you think it is do
various types of filtering to try and
make sure that the information is
consistent for the use cases that you
have in mind because your data may cover
other use cases that go beyond the scope
of what you're interested in doing which
has something to do with normalization
as well and the other thing that we've
noticed is these so these error feedback
loops where errors propagate somebody
found an error you went to a website you
got some information you read it great
you write a paper but there was an error
in that paper that they may have gone
back and they've corrected but now you
put inside your system the erroneous
data and meanwhile someone else found it
inside your system put it in
I in their system and then we end up
getting all this data back some of its
been corrected some of it hasn't been
corrected it may have been corrected
them a particular moment in time or it
may reflect the errors that were in the
actual original document and you want to
preserve that in certain cases but as a
process of doing that you may be pushing
out erroneous information for people who
don't know and are in the know you you
wouldn't know what to say oh well this
was tell me it's a and this one's tell
me it's be oh yeah but we already knew
that a is B but we do it we have to keep
it this way because what the original
publication said okay so known unknowns
there's this guy named Donald Rumsfeld
and he had this thing there are known
knowns there are things that we know
that we know but they're also there are
known unknowns which is to say that
there are some things we we do not know
we know that we don't know but there are
also unknown unknowns and things we
don't know what to do about it well in
the case of chemical space you know we
have to know our information and to see
well what are our known knowns and known
unknowns and try and get a handle on
what are some of the unknown unknowns
and chemical information is is well it's
complex you have a particular chemical
structure but you can take that same
chemical structure and you can draw it
in a myriad of different ways because
they have these things called tautomers
and resonance forms and whatnot but all
these things that I'm showing you here
are all guanine but these are different
ways that we see the same thing but
knowing that we have this issue we can
start to think about how we might be
able to correct or do something about it
in chemistry structures aren't they can
have multiple different forms naturally
so here's a natural product which is
from a defence chemical of a domino
glands of Roe beetle species well this
natural product can be representing this
form in that form they're both correct
but in your use case you might think
ones
more correct than the other some people
when you deal with information you you
can represent it in different ways much
like you can with in the case of
something called sodium acetate acetic
acid to something you have inside
vinegar if you react it with sodium you
make sodium acetate well some people
like to show just acetic acid in the
sodium metal as opposed to having
something that somehow combined together
but when you start to think about this
information if you think these are
different you might have an issue but if
you knew that they're the same it may be
helpful and how you think about the
information how you combine it later and
then you can take the same information
that you say okay now i understand it
but now you change the context here's
the chemical context and here's the
biomedical context sodium acetate is a
trihydrate it's a very specific thing to
say that it absorbs water and this is
how you would buy it and so on but the
same thing can have a different meaning
as you change the context or your use
case data normalization improves utility
by helping to find a refine your
identification so now you understand
what some of your issues are you can
design some type of a platform and this
is this is what we do with hours to
clean up our chemical structures to
normalize them but you can imagine with
your information content you could
normalize it so these different
representations of the same thing may
only have a single form for example or
you have other ways that you can
collapse down things that are equivalent
or near equivalent into something that
can help you to stitch together the
fabric of your data so in some ways
you're starting to already add structure
to your information by doing these types
of normalization steps trust but verify
there's this famous guy you know back in
in the 80s every time he was dealing
with the the Russians and it came with
these ICBM treaties he would always say
trust but verify which is actually a
Russian proverb and I'm not going to try
to pronounce it but you know he is
interesting to see that you know yes you
have something that you an information
source that you have but when do
know when to trust it if you just trust
it blindly you may be very disappointed
and there's this other famous guy John
Kerry when dealing with this more
recently with the syria chemical weapons
disposal thought well you know maybe we
should change its not trust but verify
but verify and verify which is to say
that with your information that you have
you better make sure that it's as
supreme as you can but it may require to
go through extensive steps to try and
well be sure you have what you think you
have within the context of your
scientific data so to give you an
example for things that are important
for pubchem we took various disease
ontology xand vocabularies and it across
comparison to see well how do they
compare between their their disease
concepts well we use mesh as a medical
subject heading which is from the
National Library medicine use index the
biomedical edit literature it has a it's
a series of dictionaries one of which
includes lots of disease concepts but
the idea here is not necessarily look at
all these numbers but to notice that a
lot of these numbers are not a hundred
percent or in the 90s there in the low
30's or even in the tens which is to say
that the concepts use for diseases
across these various ontology xand and
and things are people use a structure
their data they don't necessarily agree
which is to say that you either need to
mash them up in some way or to somehow
disambiguate those things that these
concepts describe they may be describing
similar things or related things or
complete a similar things and if you
don't get a handle on this when you add
structure to your data which most people
are using ontology Xand classification
systems vocabularies to do to modify
their data or say to add structure to
your big data you might find a lot of
video sync receives when you go from one
vocabulary scheme or concepts came in
and go to another and it may be that you
have to do multiple mapping somehow get
a handle on what's going on there
consistency filtering improves precision
by removal outliers so if you can
imagine you have some type of a target
and the most usual thing that you're
really really hoping for is that you get
everything right in the center of the
target everything is grouped really
close together would just say it's
precise and its biggest in the center
target it's very accurate well you have
big data you don't necessarily
understand the accuracy of it per se
however you can improve the precision
you may not be at the center but at
least you can eliminate the outliers so
your data isn't as scattered by having
various means of consistency filtering
you can somehow get a handle on how
varied your answers are for the same
information to give you some ideas on
the on the pubchem side we were looking
at various aspects about how we have
different structures associated to
different chemical concepts found within
various types of vocabularies and
designing various ways that we can
minimize the spread to say that multiple
chemicals are being referred to by the
the same concept you know sometimes
chemical names can be very promiscuous
DNA we all know what DNA is right die
nitro Dino Joanna lean in this case you
know one could say okay I think of DNA
is one thing in one context but it could
mean one two three or four other things
as well and you have to be careful when
you do a mashup to your your
vocabularies to make sure that they're
actually dealing with the same
information but the really the take-home
message for us is that we were able to
eliminate for the same queries we're
basically able to pick a chemical or at
least to find one that's consistent
between our contributors and to get some
sort of a crowdsource idea of what's
going on with this information so the
idea here is we can keep the consensus
and get rid of the rest we don't
eliminate it in fact we keep all of the
original information we as an archive we
preserve all of the data we don't get
rid of
anything however we can hide a lot of
the information by default but that we
can also do is to focus the information
so that when you query say for aspirin
you don't see tylenol because you know
you have aspirin free tylenol has
aspirin is a key word in that and
sometimes people get confused and say oh
well tylenol is aspirin as a result of
that because when they search for
aspirin they didn't get what they
expected and they look at the results
that come back and say oh your database
is full of errors not necessarily full
of errors it just handled things that
you weren't necessarily expecting and if
you're looking to use something for
research-based purposes you know
typically what we would do is just put
the most likely answer at the top but
then we just have some sort of a Down
weighted set of results as things become
well less specific we found that was not
what our users expected they expect to
see the correct answer and just the
correct answer and nothing else but you
might find the same thing too is that if
you start to harness big data you might
find you query something you get lots of
answers for the same question but it
doesn't necessarily mean that they're
wrong it could simply mean that you
haven't normalized and filtered down
your information to the point where for
your use cases you're happy with the
answers you get back and that can be
difficult to do in the case of chemicals
there are lots of things that can go
wrong in part because you might draw
your chemical structure and it could be
absolutely correct but then you save it
and you save it into a format but then
you load it back into your software
again it may or may not be exactly the
same way that you had it before so when
you move data around between different
archives and resources not just chemical
information but data in general every
time you touch it with an algorithm or
import or export it from a software
package you may or may not have the
exact same thing that you started with
in fact we could start to see patterns
in what software even software versions
that were being
use when people are giving us data from
various sources we've even invented a
term called Robo chemistry to describe
what's going on in that every time
algorithms we're touching the chemical
structures and doing some type of
normalization in some cases they were
horribly corrupting the structures and
amino to reconstitute them in some way
became somewhat problematic but then you
know people were saying oh well your
structures are wrong inside your system
but they weren't necessarily wrong is
that they got corrupted even curated
information is getting corrupted when
these types of things happen so you have
to be very careful with how you handle
the information whether you're a
downstream user or the one creating
these types of archives because strange
things happen when you apply software to
data and even if as you structure data
inside the database you may change its
meaning so you have to be very careful
addressing feedback loops well you know
one thing that we sort of came up with
is we started to create whitelists gray
lists and black lists so a white list is
to say i am absolutely perfectly happy
with I know that this thing is that and
you set it in stone it can only be that
because we do various types of things
with filtering and normalization it's
possible that as a function of time the
correct answer becomes wrong because
someone gives you the same information
erroneously multiple times and if you're
using various types of cleanup
algorithms the correct answer get the
signal gets drowned out for the noise
well one way to address that is by
saying oh it can only be this but in
some cases you can only narrow it down
you can narrow it down to a list of
candidates because you know it can't be
anything else but those things and you
can then apply your consistency rules
based on that I've already shown you
lost different ways chemical structures
can be represented but the same thing is
true for sequences or other types of
scientific data it could also be in the
case of physical properties or spectra
or other things like that where you
might not have the exact same thing
but you know it's close to it or it has
to be one of these things and if all
else fails you can create is not less
this is typically what we do to fix
errors quick which is to say that this
thing cannot be that but really the
errors of what it cannot be is infinite
so really this is not a winning strategy
to say okay I'm going to say it's not
that because someone else can create
some new error tomorrow and you won't
filter that one out it's better in many
cases to triage things down to say well
what can it be the other thing that
we've really tried to do is to prevent
aeration at the data source when people
give us information we subjected to all
types of analyses and we'll tell them
when they're making things worse we've
also have engaged and worked with a lot
of manual curation efforts that exist
worldwide in fact their governments that
fund various types of projects that do
manual curation these are tens of people
students oftentimes paid to curate
information but when I cross compare
this curate information i often find
errors human errors silly errors or most
times they do a great job but I find
that when I helped to combine these
together and then work with these I get
a positive feedback loop and that they
start to converge on the proper answers
but all's I can do is say look you're
inconsistent are you correct and
oftentimes we get the feedback that in
some cases there are some real
disagreements as to what the real
structures are or what the data is but
often times it start to dialogue that
those communities can work on and fix
and I can stay out of it for the most
part and they can you know do the parts
that need to be done but really if you
can with your big data or your big data
sources if you can let them know what's
wrong and help them to mitigate the
errors the next time you get an update
maybe these problems go away for you
because oftentimes they're experts in
these areas and they're better situated
and often times may be better funded to
correct these types of issues and you
are because if you just fix it for
yourself anybody else who uses this day
and then you then they copy it and then
put into their resource and then you
start to use them you start to see the
same error over there so oftentimes it's
better to I think you know kill the the
error at the source when it can be
identified so in terms of my top five or
or five quick error suppression
strategies identify quality understand
your information the known knowns that
the known unknowns and so on normalize
your information trust your data but
verify it cross compare it work with
your various types of curated sources
and if you don't have multiple sources
get them so you can get some second
opinions or third opinions about what
things are the more opinions the better
in my my mind consistency filtering can
help a whole lot oftentimes it removes a
lot of the fuzz in the information that
you have and if you don't do this you
might find that you get many more
answers back in your analyses than if
you do some type of a filtering down you
can always expose this information out
afterwards after do your analysis about
the other equivalent forms or near forms
that maybe abuse and the last definitely
address your error feedback loops
especially if you're dealing with
multiple data sources all right now
while you clean with your data but it's
huge I'm we only too unwieldy and
structured how can be made more useful
well one way is crawling can annotate
your data provided better context and
edify associated concepts establish
similarity schemes so you can find near
neighbors and related records associate
the things to concept hierarchies
wherever in however you can to help you
navigate between records perform various
types of data reduction to suppress your
redundant information oftentimes you're
going to find you have lots of the same
thing again and again and last find ways
to be succinct basically by hiding a lot
of the details that that's available to
give you some idea is what we do inside
pubchem is you know we have information
about this substance is somehow relate
to a protein we can start to tell you
things well it inhibits this protein or
it's mentioned inside this particular
publication this gene is somehow
expresses this protein and so on we can
start to expose these types of cross
links otherwise we just have simply bags
and substances bags of proteins and
links between things without any context
I'm running out of time here but the
other thing about establishing
similarity schemes it's kind of like the
Russian dolls right a doll inside a doll
inside a doll and if you have some way
of hierarchy to express information you
can sort of zoom in or zoom out on your
information data oh we harness this for
for chemical records by allowing to find
similar related information rapidly by
associating things concept hierarchies
you have a hierarchy you can sociate
chemicals proteins genes patents
publications whatever you want to it
it's a way to navigate the information
that's there will we do this inside
pubchem we can tell you things about a
particular chemical or entity or target
based on these hierarchies but it also
allows us to allow you to browse our
entire contents using them or to mine
them the last point is is really a two
one two different points and it really
comes down to how you can reduce your
data down into simple statements in this
case we're using a linked data or rdf
you can say something them on the orders
of a tour visat Matri hypocalcemia you
have some type of a subject predicate
object trio but you also have provenance
information if you reduce your data down
to these types of statements it can
really help but if you want to be
succinct if you leave out the provenance
information it can really simplify
things a lot because we find that we get
the same information again and again and
a lot of it we we tell you well where
did it come from who gave it to us where
did they get their information so on so
again a top five four ways you can
organize your data and just give you
some including remarks scientific big
data it contains an amazing amount of
information I mean you know really
groundbreaking stuff that allows you to
have opportunities to make new
discoveries if you just simply knew to
ask the right questions that the data is
organized in just
the right way you can connect the dots
and make true discoveries it's already
there it can benefit from strategies to
massage this data and pubchem is trying
to do its part in this area at least
within the space that we are in chemical
biology we're trying to make the
chemical data very broadly accessible to
you so that you can make more use of it
in the case of Wolfram they could put it
inside their alpha system and and and do
more with this type of data we cross
integrated to various key scientific
resources so you can find other related
information and we're doing our best to
sort of suppress their errors and
propagation of those errors but also
making it organized you can take better
use of it pubchem is a project with a
number of us working on it talented
group of folks and if you have any
questions I'd be happy to answer them if
there's any time it but if you think of
something later if you don't think of or
have time to answer ask question now
feel free to email me thank you